Cuba and the Cuban revolution would continue
fighting and they would continue
resisting me and my picket no we do not
subtract from that communist [ __ ]
My name is Eagle I am the director
of the band for Ricardo and I am here I
believe that dinosaurs do not exist we
all believe that dinosaurs do not exist
What if
you are a musician in Cuba
is something that is difficult to sustain.
If you are not mixed with the
institutions, even if you are also
mixed with the institutions,
the situation is difficult
for the Cuban musician. In other words, I think that for all Cubans
it is difficult.  situation, even if you are a
musician, even if it
is not jazz, it was also seen as the
music of the enemy. This was what
Chucho Vald spoke about in an interview once.
For them you showed that a
path of distortion of deviation from
their
ideology knew that this music was very
powerful to transmit ideas and they
saw it at that time as the deviation
of everything they proposed and what they
wanted for the
youth to me.  I like punk I
really like sex pistol I like Black
Flag that type that type of Clash stuff
too
and well in Cuba it has been very difficult
to get all kinds of
information, not only artistic
but of all kinds, I mean I spoke on
several occasions  We were talking about how the
information came like 10 years
later regarding the music it was very
difficult. That's why I listened to bands like
Leel in the 80s and that kind of
stuff now now Med
is a little easier to get
information about that
kind of stuff.
ric music, to simplify, I always
say that it is the opposite of homeland
dead, homeland for me is a
collective conglomerate Ricardo is an individual
and pornography is pleasure is enjoyment is
life and death is death in other words porn for
Ricardo is the opposite of homeland
death now well eh  We were
recording the last album, this album
now, and the police come and arrest us and they do
n't tell us why, inside the
prison at the police station, they
tell me that it's for predictive behavior, that
's something they usually do.
with people like us who
are against the regime because it is
very easy since they do not have a
solid pretext, they use this law that is very applicable to
us, which is a
social danger, they say that this is
very happening, on this occasion something happens that was
not unprecedented.  In Cuba, according to
my
information, they released me due to
international pressure on
solidarity that existed outside the country and
within the country and they changed the
crime to a crime that was
cooler cool you
is what's the other's name I
remember
disobedience And  So well, I am
proud of what happened because
there were a lot of people and that had never been
achieved in my country that with someone
with an
established sentence, even when I hold you in
court there may be a sentence and they
have already released me with this one, changing the
first one.  The first
Sentence
is very difficult. We play at
most once a year. It is very very very
difficult for us to organize a
concert. That is something that
the
government has taken from us. We cannot play. You can imagine
how important it is for a group to play
for an audience.  and more for us
because we have a
very projection between us and we
sometimes break the barrier of the status of the
group playing and the public. Sometimes we
mix, the public goes up and we
go down and then that is one thing that
the government has taken away from us, it is very
difficult.  For us, playing, what
we do mostly is record the albums
and we give them away to the public, that's what
we mostly do, central committee, the people
commanding death, it remains the same,
obviously, freedom,
that is, freedom, individual freedom,
means, uh, it's very linked to  What is
development? In other words, when you take away
a man's freedom, you took away almost
half of his life, you took away much
more, and and and decay begins at every
level. In other words, freedom is important
for development if there is something good that
happens.  In Cuba it must be freedom, I
wanted to bus my tiredness with my little
courage and I'm
leaving.